[Musique]
la presse quotidienne régionale et les
télévisions locales vous
présentent le club des
territoires et avec nous pour ce club
des territoires Florence Sportelli
bonjour merci d'être là ma les
républicains de Tavern et dans le
valdoise vice-président de l'Association
des maires de France Christophe Rouillon
bonjour merci également d'être avec nous
ma socialiste coulen dans la SAR et
également vice-président de
l'Association des maires de France et
Denis Turiot bonjour merci d'être là
maire renaissance de neure dans la
Nièvre et président de l'Assemblée des
territoires du parti présidentiel merci
à tous les trois d'être là alors que
s'ouvre le Congrès des Maires vous nous
direz dans quel état d'esprit vous êtes
à mi-mandat et puis on parlera plus
précisément de l'aprèseut où en est la
reconstruction alors que des mairies et
des écoles ont été dégradées avec des
maires parfois lâchés par leurs
assureurs on verra notre reportage et
puis audrait vous nous rappelez les
réponses du gouvernement ces avec
notamment une proposition de l'exécutif
de donner des pouvoirs de police
nationale à la police municipale on
parle de tout ça tout de suite dans ce
[Musique]
club et on commence par notre reportage
après les émeutes leur est au compte
pour les Mairies touché mais les
assureurs ne sont pas toujours au
rendez-vous jonathan dupriz est allé
rencontrer deux élus au petitkeville
dans la bonlie de rouant et Arcueil en
région
parisienne petit queevilli dans
l'agglomération de rouan lors des
émeutes l'école maternelle de ce
quartier prioritaire a été attaqué et
incendi un choc toujours persistant pour
les élus de la commune s'attaquer à
l'école c'est quand même la République
c'est le lieu du savoir de
l'émancipation par la culture par la
connaissance oui c'est très choquant au
total 136000 € de dégâts un sinistre que
la commune déclare immédiatement à son
assureur nous avions une franchise de
100000 € dans le contrat ce qu'on n'a
jamais contesté elle nous a donc va nous
verser les 36000 € que de dédommagement
sauf que dans le même temps la compagnie
d'assurance elvécia France adresse un
courrier à la mairie sur cette lettre
l'assureur décide de révoquer
unilatéralement son engagement nous
avons le regret de vous informer par la
présente tête recommandée de la
résiliation du contrat c-dessus ce qui
nous a vraiment mis en colère c'est
cette rupture de contrat qui pour nous
était un peu abusif quoi parce que c'est
un contrat qui avait été prévu sur 3 ans
et qui était reconductible tous les ans
par ta cite reconduction entre les deux
parties la mairie décide d'aller au bras
de faire pour que l'assureur la couvre
de nouveau elle médiatise l'affaire
adresse un courrier à la première
ministre et même au président du Sénat
mais rien y fait à ce stade la commune
n'est plus assurée au 1er janvier
prochain comme à petit kevilli des
centaines de communes seraient concerné
par un désengagement de leur assureur
après les violences urbaines selon cette
journaliste spécialiste de l'assurance
les émeutes chiffré à 730 millions
d'euros de dégâts ont été la goutte
d'eau qui a fait déborder le vase avec
la multiplication des risques
climatiques notamment assurer une
collectivité n'est presque plus rentable
c'est la branche des assurances qui sur
lesqueles les assureurs ne gagnent pas
d'argent du tout voire en perdent
donc la plupart des assureurs se sont
retirés de ce marché qui n'est pas
intéressant pour eux enfin qui qui qui
met même en jeu leur survie et si les
assureurs ne se désengagent pas ils
comptent faire exploser leurs tarifs
c'est ce qui est arrivé à la mairie
d'Arcueil en banlieu parisienne au
retour de l'été le maire tombe de sa
chaise à la lecture d'un avenant en cas
de sinistre lié aux émeutes la franchise
de la commune passera de 1500 à 2
million d'euros toutes les grosses
communes de France un peu près 150
semble-t-il ont reçu exactement cette
même lettre et donc c'est une enfin
c'est un espèce de retrait en tout cas
en se mettant dans des conditions qui
sont des
conditions je dirais inacceptables même
si on est amené à les accepté de peur
d'être sans assurance arcil a fini par
se plier aux conditions de la compagnie
mais avec cette explosion des couts la
mairie devra sans doute faire des
arbitrages budgétaires au risque de
diminuer la qualité du service public il
y a une école qui est brûlée dans une
émeute il y a 6 millions pour
reconstruire l'école l'assurance nous
couvre 2 millions il faut trouver 4
millions dans le budget de la ville pour
reconstruire cette école 4 millions pour
une ville comme Arcueil c'est à peu près
le budget d'investissement annuel signe
de la tension qui règne entre élus et
assurance les compagnies que nous avons
contacté n'ont pas souhaité s'exprimer
avant le congrès des maires
parallèlement une médiation entre
l'Association des maires de France et
les assureurs a été lancé par l'État et
devrait rendre ses conclusions au mois
d'avril prochain on va dans ce reportage
de Jonathan du PRI soit des maires qui
sont lâchés par leurs assureurs soit des
tarifs d'assurance qui sont exorbitants
est-ce que vous connaissez les mêmes
problèm vous Florence sportalier avec
les assurances alors en grande couronne
nous passons par le centre
interdépartemental de gestion donc c'est
quand même 195 communes d'île-de-fance
qui sont concernés qu' pour des
questions évidentes d'efficacité de
mutualisation on a préféré passer par un
groupement de commande le CIG c'est une
instance normalement qui n'a aucune
difficulté à trouver des assureurs ils
ont passé à un marché donc pour une
commande groupée et ça a été infructueux
zéro retour pas d'assurance donc là ils
sont obligés de ils ont dû resouscrire
enfin redéposer leurs demande et nous
attendons la réponse incessamment sous
peu en espérant que cette fois-ci il y a
eu des réponses parce que on entend dans
le reportage aujourd'hui c'est plus
rentable pour les assurances d'assurer
les collectivités territoriales on va
vers des difficultés à venir écoutez moi
je pense que c'est rentable et qu' à un
moment il faut aussi que l'Étap tape du
point sur la table parce que c'est
scandaleux de se comporter comme ça et
et d'ailleurs il y a il n'y a pas que ça
comme difficulté quand vous avez même
parfois des petites dégradations mais
quand même des dégradations qui coûtent
on est beaucoup de mairies à se dire
finalement à cause de la franchise mieux
vaut ne pas déclarer mais c'est vrai que
les assurances n'ont pas un comportement
honnête dans l'histoire je le civisme ça
concerne pas que les entités publiques
ça peut aussi concerner les entreprises
privées don faut que l'État tape du
point sur la table comme oui bien sûr je
pense que le système des assurances est
largement rentable et que d'abord on est
souvent comme ma è l'a dit notre propre
assureur he parce que soit il y a une
franchise élevée soit parce qu'on assure
une enveloppe et qu'on sait que le
surplus ça coûtera trop cher donc on
préfère l'assurer nous-même je prends
l'exemple d'un agent parce que je l'ai
eu dans ma commune qui dégrade avec un
véhicule un équipement de la commune on
n pas d'assurance de toute façon donc il
y a des tas de de de de fois où on
intervient mais aujourd'hui c'est ce qui
ce que reçoivent certaines communes
c'est pas mon cas les résidiations à
cause d'événements liés à des tiers
c'est insupportable ça sert à ça
l'assurance donc c'est injuste et nous
travaillons au niveau de l'assemblée des
territoir avec le gouvernement avec
Dominique fort avec violet spilebou un
projet de loi sur les violences faites
aux élus et plus largement sur le statut
de l'élu de façon transpartisane
d'ailleurs et aussi moi je je le propose
un droit à l'assurance et notamment en
prévision des prochaines élections
notamment municipales on risque d'avoir
un certain nombre de candidats et donc
aussi prévoir le droit à l'assurance des
candidats sinon ça va être compliqué
qu'ils puissent assurer leurs locaux de
campagne par exemp quel forme un droit à
l'assurance pour être en écoutez il y a
des droits à l'assurance minimum quand
on circule en voiture on est obligé
d'être assuré et ben quand on se
présente en campagne la verser il faut
qu'on ait un droit à être assuré de plus
en plus de de de Mair ou de candidats
sont victimes sur leur bien personnels
sur leur maison ça a été mon cas sur
leor je suis avocat mon cavid avocat fa
détruit pas les gilets jaunes donc voilà
il faut aussi prévoir l'outil de travail
de candidats qui viennent du monde privé
qui sont exposé faudrait aussi un droit
à un compte en banque hein pour un
compte de campagne bah pareil voilà il a
pasoui bien sr par chance nous avons
nous n'avons pas de problème avec notre
assureur la ville a été victime d'une
attaque d'un incendie de de l'hôtel de
ville mais nous sommes bien assurés sal
Mel duent je suis pas de publicité nous
sommes d' Dieu duent et en tout cas nous
allons sur 200000 € de travaux il y a
140000 € qui sont pris en charge par par
l'assurance et également 60000 € par par
l'État mais ça n'empêche pas que je
connais beaucoup de mes qui sont dans
une situation très difficile et Don donc
là effectivement il faut faire avancer
les choses pour que voilà les les
communes ne soient pas pénalisées et
assument des risques très importants
parce qu'on a comm parfois des sinistres
qui ont conduit les mires à augmenter de
50 % les impôts parce qu'il y avait eu
un incendie ou une dégradation
volontaire sur sur un bâtiment public
vos trois communes ont été touchées
durant les les émeutes à divers degrés
on va en parler on en est où 5 mois
après de la reconstruction de niturio
écoutez on n pas été le plus touché mais
on a quand même été touché et et surtout
les particuliers qu'on accompagne par
exemple sur les véhicules une trentaine
de véhicules brûlés donc certains ont
connu des difficultés pour d'autres s
aller et c'est ça qu'on qu'on voit
souvent c'est la façon de traitement des
assurances qui est diverse et variée
donc nous on est accompagnant pour le
privé parce que c'est normal de les
aider et puis pour nos biens pour
l'instant ben les choses suivent son
cours et je dois dire que pour nov on a
pas de difficulté majeur et notre
assureur semble assumer Florence
Portelli vous aussi il y a eu des il y a
eu des dégâts dans dans votre commune
alors là où il y en a eu le plus on va y
venir he c'est chez vous Christophe
Rouillon vous il y a eu des dégâts un
peu moins vous en est tous al
honnêtement pas tant que ça mais pas
tant que ça grâce à l'héroïsme de la
police municipale de ma ville et je
tiens vraiment à saluer les héros que
sont les policiers municipaux on n parle
pas ass souvent ils sont traités comme
des sous-policiers ça fait très
longtemps que je j'appelle l'État à
changer de regard je l'avais fait aussi
d'ailleurs au moment de la réforme des
retraites où un coup il est très aisé de
les considérer comme des fonctionnaires
territoriaux et d'autrefois de
considérer justement que ce sont des
policiers qui remplacent en fait la
police nationale parce que je peux vous
dire que dans le valdoise on n' pas
assez de policiers on n'a pas assez de
policier donc ils ont tenu en fait la
caserne des pompiers sinon elle brûlait
et peut-être avec les pompiers dedans
j'ai des voyous qui ont attaqué la
caserne des pompiers on en est là dans
ce pays les pompiers donc on a passé une
une nuit blanche j'allais dire à River
sur les les informations que nous
donnait la police municipale et les
pompiers à 3h du matin et voilà là où on
en est ben je vous dirais que on en est
dans une société qui a perdu ses repères
et peut-être aussi que la réponse doit
être un peu moins courtermiste va
revenir sur la question des polices
municipales ça ça fait partie des
réponses du gouvernement vous c'est vous
qui avez connu parmi les les mère ici
présent Christophe Ron le plus de dégâts
c'est la mairie qui a été attaquée à
coulen 5 mois après vous en êtes où mais
on a lancé des procédure de de de choix
des entreprises et il va falloir encore
3 mois pour pour réparer les dégâts de
l'accueil voilà c'était c'était un choc
pour les habitants pour la ville parce
que c'est quand même un symbole de
s'attaquer à un hôtel de ville par
chance nous n'avons pas eu de beaucoup
d'autres dégâts mais c'est l'hôtel de
ville et ça était vraiment c'est vrai un
symbole un petit peu de du comportement
totalement inadmissible d'une poignée de
voyou qui ont des décidé voilà de
s'attaquer à la République que vous
expliquez comment pass c'est vrai
qu'elles ont eu un visage particulier
ces émeutes à la fois par les villes
attaquées qui ne sont pas uniquement des
grandes villes des villes de banlieu
mais beaucoup de villes moyennes voir de
petites villes et en même temps beaucoup
d'écoles et de mairies qui ont été
attaqué vous l'expliquer comment ben je
pense qu'il y a parfois un bras de fer
par rapport à certaines organisations
criminelles qui ne supportent pas le
travail de la police moi j'ai pas de
police municipale dans la ville mais on
a une police d'État qui fait bien son
travail en dehors de ça on a une ville
plutôt calme c'est une ville avec 50
pour de logements sociaux beaucoup
d'action d'ailleurs le calme est revenu
par la suite même si maintenant on sent
à nouveau des des tensions réapparaître
donc je pense qu'il faut à la fois une
main tendue avec des actions sociales
éducatives et cetera mais il faut aussi
une fermeté parce que les citoyens ne
peuvent pas accepter d'être menacés
d'avoir des des tirs de mortiers d'avoir
des gens qui font des rodéau sauvages
voilà donc je pense qu'il faut tenir les
deux choses à la fois de la fermeté et
puis aussi avoir des politique de
prévention parce que la répression ne
règlera pas tous les problèmes notamment
vis-à-vis du trafic de drogue exactement
elle est suffisamment là cette fermeté
de turio ça c'est la réponse pénale et
en tant qu'avocat je suis bien blasé
pour savoir que justement il y a la
séparation des pouvoir et que quoi qu'on
en dise l'État ne peut pas donner
d'injonction au juge du siège pour dire
il faut telle sanction telle sanction
après il peut y avoir des orientations
du garde des saut vis-àvis du parquet ça
c'est un autre sujet même l'avoc c'est
uniquement la réponse pénale ou c'est
aussi un signal d'autorité qui doit être
envoyé par l'État ben je pense qu'il a
un signal d'autorité mais je pense qu'il
est dit il est fait et quand on envisage
qu'il va être fait sur le plan antibut
on voit bien qu'il y a une volonté de
reprend prendre en main après c'est
suffisant ça ne l' pas c'est un sujet
délicat mettre l'armée dans les
quartiers ça peut être tantant il y a la
façon de le faire et c'est ce qui peut
être prévu par les forces d'action qui
sont envisagées on voit surtout qu'il y
a une démission parentale d'éducation je
veux pas jouer les moralis ici mais il y
a un problème de respect global des
professions des élus des biens publics
et donc il y a un problème comment faire
pour faire pour pour évoluer
cette appréhension de de la chose
publique qui n existe plus aujourd'hui
on voit bien qu'il y a plus de frein
chez certains puis il y a l'effet de
masse qui n'est pas nouveau mais qui se
démultiplie par les réseaux je vois ne
et je salue aussi ce qu'a fait la les
polices parce que finalement une
coordination gendarmerie police moi j'ai
une police intercommunale on a évité que
d'autres villes qui étaient appelées par
les réseaux viennent et sinon ça aurait
pris une autre dimension bien évidemment
donc il faut une réponse pénale et même
l'avocat que je suis trouve que parfois
la réponse pénale est insuffisante voyez
alors que je vous parle cet après-midi
il y a quelqu'un qui m'injurie sur les
réseaux sociaux qui comparaît enfin au
correctionnel il va falloir qu'il assume
euh donc mais c'est pas moi ni
gouvernement qui va dire au juste qu'il
faut mettre sur les dégradations quand
ce sont des dégradations légères moi je
prô de plus en plus que soit proposé des
des TIG travail d'intérêt général ça
m'intéresserait quelqu'un qui dégrade un
bien public vienent le nettoyer et
vienent en nettoyer d'autres par exemple
he mais il faut l'accord la personne
c'est comme ça c'est le droit il faut
que ça soit proposé par le parquet
flence partel oui alors ce que dit notre
collègue est tout à fait vrai
heureusement le magistrat du siège est
totalement indépendance c'est article 66
de la Constitution c'est un principe
fondamental mais vous remarquerez
régulièrement que des décisions qui
peuvent sembler choquantes même si on n'
pas commenté une décision de justice
suscite souvent l'appel du parquet qui
lui répond finalement à une commande
politique et heureusement parfois qu'il
a l'appel du parquet parce que là je
vraiment moi je tire la so d'alarme une
justice trop coupé de ses concitoyens ça
devient dangereux dans un état de droit
c'est le cas aujourd'hui et c'est le cas
aujourd'hui trop coupé aussi de sa
police qui ne comprend pas certaines
décisions et qui se sont abandonné donc
nous arrivons aujourd'hui à une fracture
qui est extrêmement dangereuse sur les
tiges je suis entièrement d'accord vous
savez pendant des années je crois que
j'ai été un des rares mare à supplier
qu'on m'envoie des tiges faut savoir
quand même que le délet moyen d'une
exécution d'un travail d'intérêt général
entre la le prononcer de la peine et
l'exécution c'est 400 jours c'est
scandaleux alors qu'il y a quelques
maires au moins qui sont volontaires
pour ça après je vous dirais de manière
plus globale ou le problème de la outre
le problème de la fermeté c'est vraiment
un problème beaucoup plus enraciné qui
un problème d'approuvirissement
intellectuel un problème de bêtises un
manque d'éducation un manque de
responsabilité un besoin profond de
réformé pour moi l'école qui est la base
de la République si l'école est attaqué
la République est attaquée et je pense
que le paquet il doit être mis là-dedans
et qu'on a trop perdu de temps depuis
des décennies et que c'est là-dessus
qu'il devrait y avoir une parole forte
sur l'éducation sur l'instruction et
tant que vous ne ferez pas ça vous aurez
des gamins qui en plus ont un manque
cruel d'empathie il y a une indifférence
à la souffrance de l' une indifférence à
la situation de l'autre un égotisme
absolument incroyable et ça ça puisse
ses racin justement dans la petite
enfance et dans l'enfance et c'est
làdessus qu'il faut mettre le paquet
partager ce qu' je pense qu'il faut des
moyens supplémentaires pour l'éducation
parce que il faut traiter bien entendu
les cas qui sont les plus difficiles
ceux qui ont basculer dans la dercance
qui n'ont comme l' dit Florence à
l'instant plus de limite ils n'ont plus
de surmoi c'està-dire qu' sont dans dans
système de réaction aussi d'argent
facile mais par contre la grande masse
des des jeunes ont encore sont encore
porteurs d'espoir et dans dans ma ville
99 % des enfants n'ont pas participé aux
éud donc nous avons en particulier
besoin de moyens de l'État euh moi je
demande depuis des années que les écoles
de ma ville soient classées en r plus
nous demandons une cite éducative nous
le nous ne l'obtenons pas et puis aussi
c'est ce que j'avais dit lorsqu'on a été
reçu à l'Élysée c'est-à-dire qu'il y a
un certain nombre de jeunes qui doivent
être sortis des quartiers d'une façon ou
d'une autre euh moi j'ai une dizaine de
jeunes ils n'ont plus rien à faire dans
les quartiers parce que voilà ils sont
pris en en ils sont pris dans des
groupes il faut à la fois les mettre
peut-être en pension dans les centres
éducatifs fermés euh je pense pas que
l'armée doit venir dans nos carer par
contre certains jeunes pourrai être
envoyés à l'armée ça leur ferait du bien
et puis dans d'autres cas c'est vrai
qu'il faut une réponse pénale quand on
voit un jeune qui met en danger ses
concitoyens en conduisant une voiture
haut de gamme et cetera qui roule àesens
à 17 ans sans permis je suis désolé il
faut il faut qu'il y ait une réponse
pénale forte il compris par la par la
détention il faut qu'-ceil faut est-ce
qu'il faut aussi une responsabilisation
des parents
mais parfois dans certains cas vous
savez moi j'ai des parents qui sont
complètement débordés les pauvres il n'y
arrivent pas c'estàd qu'une femme seule
avec trois enfants elle a deux enfants
qui se comporte bien qui réussi c'est le
troisème fait n'importe quoi elle n'y
arrive pas donc dans certains cas on a
des parents démissionnaires et là moi je
suis pour l'expulsion y compris des
logements locatifs pour des sanctions et
dans d'autres cas il faut aider les
parents y compris en sortant ces jeunes
délinquants des quartiers
oui je suis entièrement d'accord avec ça
en fait on a deux catégories de parents
vous avez le parents qui
largué ou dans des grandes difficultés
sociales on a de plus en plus de
familles monoparentales avec des femmes
qui se retrouvent seules alors le le
père il s'est pardon il s'est barré il
est complètement
démissionnaire et c'est extrêmement
difficile d'aller dire à une femme qui
essaie de tenir à bout de bras son foyer
son Maum son boulot qui est souvent un
boulot précaire un boulot mal payé et
cetera il lu dire en plus on va vous
expulser serait idiot en revanche il n'y
a pas que ça et on en a j'ai des
procédures d'expulsion qui sont en cours
avec le bailleur social ou ce sont des
c'est le wo wo si vous voulez de la
récidive et de la réitération et ils
s'en fichent d'ailleurs parce qu'ils se
disent de toute façon quoi qu'il arrive
il se passera rien et le seule chose qui
puisse leur faire peur c'est quand même
d'être viré du quartier et de perdre le
logement c'est la seule chose qui compte
et moi je vais vous dire ce qui me
choque beaucoup dans ce pays un c'est
que suréducation il y a pas vraiment de
débat de fond et deux pour moi l'autre
ner de la guerre c'est le logement et il
y a pas de politique du logement
d'ailleurs quand Emmanuel Macron a été
réélu on a même une période sans
ministre du Logement et quand il a
enterré le plan borlot dans une
cérémonie indigne à l'Élysée vous
remarquerez aussi que dans ce plan le
logement était aussi assez absent et
notamment le logement social il y a une
vraie réflexion à avoir notamment sur le
parcours résidenciel sur l'accès à la
propriété sur l'émancipation des
individus et la responsabilisation le
problème c'est que ça n'intéresse
personne alors que c'est fondamental
dans nos
banlieux le logement est trop
abandonné la politiqueemu MA par on est
dans l'héritage d'une situation qu'on
pas géré depuis des décennies il y a une
accumulation peutêtre de mauvais
décision de non décisions qui on été
pris plus compliqué de
route du logement il y avait toujours
quelqu'un qui s'occupa du logement et il
y a du logement pendant plus d'un an
c'est révélateur logement nétait pas
oublié pour autant il y a les
dominations de ministère et puis y a ce
qui se fait réellement vous le savez
bien plan
borlot on est pas dans la rue Nationale
on a plus droit à rien aujourd'hui et ça
c'est pas forcément lié au gouvernement
actuel donc il faut vraiment aider les à
pouvoir construire des logements parce
mer le dire parce que je pense que c'est
un sujet très transpartisan et que
aujourd'hui il faut prendre le T par les
cornes et nous les élus le con et là en
accompagnement on n'a pas tout à assumer
mais il y a eu des erreurs de fait he
dans la façon de loger les gens
maintenant c'est pas l'origine de tout
je suis désolé il y a un prème éducatif
et die sais si je suis pas réactionnaire
je le dis laïquement il faut aujourd'hui
que certains parents parce que c'est
parfois très trans sociocial c'est pas
que les gens en difficulté qu'on parfois
déiculé avec leurs enfants on voit bien
aussi que ça rejoint parfois les
problèmes de Deal et qu'effectivement
faire le Getter on gagne bien mieux sa
vie que commencer à travailler donc il y
a un vrai sujet aussi là-dessus je sais
pas si on aura le temps d'en parler mais
euh nous on peut pas tout faire il faut
que l'État effectivement quel qu'il soit
d'ailleurs fasse des propositions qui
soient fortes vis-à-vis des parents il y
a aussi les consents de partie civil on
a retrouvé d' on parlait des tout à
l'heure des auteurs dans beaucoup de
villes grâce aux caméras de vidéo hein
il faut faire payer les parents je suis
désolé mais quand les les enfants sont
mineurs c'est la loi et c'est la règle
et quand on touche au porte-monnaie ça
permet peut-être de mobiliser davantage
je parle pas de ceux qui n'ont pas la
capacité parce que quelque part quand
onuss parents doit avoir la capacité
éducative c'est peut-être facile de le
dire mais ça doit être quand même un
accompagnement pour le reste on a des
problématiques de logement qui sont très
différentes avec des secteurs tendus des
secteurs détendus on a moyen de faire du
surmesure aujourd'hui qui sont très
détendus he sur les question de lement
par en terme technique je dire
administratif merci du jeu de M non non
mais moi j'ai bien compris que vous
aviez compris mais on peut faire de
l'humour tous les deux euh maintenant on
peut être tendu et détendu parce que moi
j'ai des j'ai des secteurs tendus malgré
quead son en secteur détendu mais je
pense pas que ça intéresse globalement
nos auditeurs d'échanger trop là-dessus
non je veux dire il faut il faut
davantage mixer mais ça c'est un vu
pieux il y a aussi on n parle pas le SNU
qui est intéressant peut-être pour
remettre aussi des jeunes dans un
certain merci ouais dans un certain
circuit ben c'est pas assez mais c'est
mieux que rien et euh je trouve que ben
il y a des jeunes moi je suis allé sou
avec saraie voir des jeunes euh qui le
faisaient et c'est une mixité parce que
là pour le coup on a des jeunes qui
viennent de tous horizons t quartiers et
à qui quelque part on réapprend c'est un
peu de l'insertion aussi quelque part ou
de l'apprentissage don voilà il y a
sûrement plein d'autres choses à faire
mais encore une fois ça sert à rien de
tirer sur le gouvernement je pense que
Gabriel Attal s'est fortement intéressé
à l'éducation depuis le début on dit on
n parle pas si je suis désolé on parle
d'éducation aujourd'hui beaucoup plus
qu'avantè on va parler desép on a aussi
un problème c'est que l'État s'est
démembré en transférant à des agences
des choses comme ça des gens qui sont
totalement éloignés des territoires
agence de rénovation urbaine anct même
s'il y a un travail qui est fait
euh l'Agence nationale de santé et
cetera et donc par exemple qu' on
interroge le ministre sur pourquoi
est-ce qu'on n' pas de crédit pour
améliorer le logement il dit c'est l' en
rue alors si vous avez pas été classé il
y a 10 ans dans le projet d'intérêt
national vous n'avez plus de droit à
rien donc il y a des projets qui sont
prêt qui sont prêts et qui sont bloqués
parce que l'État n'a plus les leviers et
c'est ça qui désespère les maires c'est
que vous n'avez plus d'interlocuteurs et
aujourd'hui quand les maires demandent
ont des revendications légitimes euh on
leur répond par SMS ou par par pardon
on répond par Twitter par Twitter j'ai
une réponse sur la cité éducative
négative sur Twitter alors que nous
avions mis 6 mois pour déposer un
dossier et c'est ça aussi qui crée la
désespérance des élus frence SP bon moi
j'avoue je suis pas du tout désespéré
j'ai une oniaque incroyable et j'ai un
espoir immense pour ce beau pays mais je
pense simplement que chacun ne prend pas
assez ses responsabilités que parfois
les problèmes sont en réalité
contrairement à ce qu'on dit aux gens
matin midi et soir c'est pas compliqué
mais qu'il y a je suis désolé pour moi
de piliers est l'éducation et le
logement je pense que le jour où on
résout ces problèmes là on résout 60 %
des problèmes non c'est pas vrai il n'y
a pas une politique du logement dans ce
pays et d'ailleurs ça se voit sur pas
mal d'aspects et même parfois des
injonctions cfcaennes quand on demande
d'un côté au maire de construire plus et
de l'autre côté qu'and il y a des
autorité environnementale de l'État qui
vous explique dans le même courrier
qu'il faut pas construire donc c'est pas
vrai on a ça ne marche pas et d'ailleurs
je suis désolée faut parler de la
délinquence dans les problèmes de
délinquence juvénile la mixité co
comment voudriez-vous qu'on arrive à
faire la mixité à l'école quand vous
n'avez pas la mixité dans le quartier
dans le logement donc en réalité c'est
intrinsèquement lié donc là-dessus il
faut vraiment qu'il y ait d'ailleurs moi
je suis prête à participer à tous les
travaux c'est pas encore la grande
blague des grandes concertations post
gilet jaunes mais avec des actions j'ai
aucun sectarisme mais je pense qu'en
effet ce ne sont pas des priorités on va
parler des réponses du gouvernement du
gouvernement borne puisque la première
ministre est une partie de son
gouvernement le 26 octobre à la Sorbonne
ont répondu euh à ces ces émeutes en
tout cas ont dévoilé leurs mesures post
émeutes avec des mesures en direction
des mer oui avec les assurances on va en
reparler pour les égrinés l'exécutif
avait réuni à la Sorbonne les 500 MRES
les plus touchés par les émeutes parmi
ces mesures on en a parlé une enveloppe
de 100 millions d'euros pour compléter
les assurances justement et aider à la
reconstruction des quartiers ce qui
devrait servir à la réparation des
salles de mobilier urbain le rachat de
bus l'exécutif qui annonce aussi des
expérimentations d'action euh de force
d'action répuque ces équipes pilotées
par le maire le préfet et le procureur
de la République vous en avez parlé
auront pour mission de rétablir la paix
publique de traiter la délinquence à la
racine et des Tuquet à la citoyenneté et
puis dernier point le gouvernement
souhaite permettre aux polices
municipales de réaliser certains actes
de police judiciaire la mesure était
déjà présente dans le projet de loi
sécurité globale mais elle avait été
retoquée par le Conseil constitutionnel
alors le ministre de l'Intérieur géralde
d'armanin propose une autre solution qui
consisterait à discuter avec les maires
de France Association des Maires de
France pour voir ceux qui veulent
rentrer de manière volontaire dans un
dispositif où on pourrait agrandir très
fortement les pouvoirs de police de la
police municipale alors on va peut-être
voir ce que vous en pensez mais certains
maires sont dubitatifs parce qu'ils
estiment que c'est une américanisation
de la police les communes les plus aisés
auront une meilleure police municipale
que les communes les plus pauvres selon
eux c'est une bonne réponse Christion
écoutez euh moi je pense qu'il faut un
retour à la police de proximité moi je
crois plutôt à la réforme de la police
qui est en cours actuellement là il y a
réflexion pour que les policiers soit
sur soit soit sur les enquêtes soit sur
le terrain et on va avoir un
renforcement des patrouilles mais
attention parce que tous les maires
n'ont pas la possibilité de se payer une
police municipale pourquo vousz pas vous
mais parce que j'ai pas les moyens
financiers c'est tout attendez je
discuté à l'instant avec Florent
politique c'est un
choix on a 150000 €
d'excédent de d'pgnonnettes 50 % des
villes françaises sont au bord de la
banque route aujourd'hui l'épargnonnette
a fondu comme neige au soleil en raison
de de l'augmentation des des salaires
décidés par l'État et des dépenses
d'énergie on n' pas les moyens de se
payer ces polices là donc on compte sur
l'état d'ailleurs on a un bon dialogue
avec la police avec le préfet il faut
que ce soit l'état qui intervienne dans
les quartiers parce que voilà c'est
c'est eux qui on sont capables de
démanteler les trafics de drogu et de
pouvoir agir concrètement sur le terrain
et puis il faut qu'on ait les moyens
aussi et là je je terminerai par ça mais
il y a beaucoup d'urgence c'està-dire il
y a beaucoup de plans ceci cela probl
c'est beaucoup de bureaucratie beaucoup
de faisons confiance au maire
donnonsleur les moyens d'agir
donneonsleur des et et faisons un bilan
à la suite là on met la charure avant
les bœ on leur demande de déposer des
projets qui nécessite beaucoup de papi
beaucoup de
bureaucratie des fonctionnaires de
l'État qui sont mobilisés alors que si
on leur donnait des sommes pour pouvoir
agir concrètement sur le terrain pour
l'éducation pour la pour le sport pour
la culture pour la prévention on aurait
plus de moyens queavec ces moyens de
avec ces politiques de de projets qui
qui font perdre beaucoup de temps
flurence sport est-ce que vous pourriez
rentrer dans le dispositif volontaire
pour donner plus de pouvoir au poli p
comme c'est c'est Al ça c'est encore des
effets de com de Gérald harmanin qui
d'ailleurs est le champion de la
mauvaise come enfin pardonin c'est comme
quand il avait expliqué quand pour les
logements sociaux on expulse le préfet
explulse le préfet nexulse pas c'est le
juge heureusement je par s le contrôle
d'un avocat mais dans un état de droit
pour s je sais que je je prne ça qu'on
puisse expulser mais dans le respect du
droit donc faire des grands effets
d'annonce parce que les gens n'y
connaîtrai rien c'est pas très
respectueux évidemment par mais non mais
c'est pas je suis facto dans le
dispositif le code général des
collectivités territoriales dispose que
le maire assure la tranquillité la
salubrité et la sécurité publique ça
fait des années qu'on demande plus de
moyens pour nos polices municipales et
je me rappelle de certains débats avec
même des députés Renaissance quand je
leur disais au moment de la réforme des
retraites ou est-ce qu'on peut pas en
profiter aussi pour aligner les
policiers municipales avec les policiers
nationaux j'avais droit à des réponses
méprisantes ça fait des années qu'on le
demande mais en dehors de cela donc déjà
un donné au maire le faire le rendre
vraiment jeallis dire magistrat premier
magistrat de la ville c'est une c'est un
titre en réalité vide et c'est aussi
là-dessus que nous devons réfléchir
après oui je suis pour plus de moyens
pour nos polices municipales notamment
d'ailleurs en matière de contrôle pas
que d'ailleurs quand ils doivent se
défendre faut savoir que quand ils
tirent au LBD quand les miens mes
policiers municipaux ont dû défendre la
caserne des pompiers tire de BD de
police municipale ça fait ça la balle ne
va pas aussi loin qu' non mais qu'un
policier national c'est des trucs
complètement dingues comme ça bon donc
si des gens pour remettre un petit peu
d'équité parce que on va nous dire ah
ben oui mais c'est pas la police
nationale oui mais maintenant on lui
demande les missions de la police
nationale donc il faut aussi qu'on
clarifie ça et puis enfin c'est on n pas
assez de policiers nationaux honnêtement
alors là-dessus c'est une responsabilité
partagée il a une responsabilité de la
droite déjà sur ce sujet-là Mo qui a
baissé les effectifs sû moi jeux pas
vous dire le contraire et là-dessus il y
a une espèce de continuité vous me direz
c'est un bon en même temps de la classe
politique mais je pense que là-dessus on
a tort et que la le service public
notamment en matière de sécurité en
matière de santé ça nécessite plus de
moyens même quand on a une dette
importante il faut savoir où on place
justement l'argent public deno réponse à
Florence Sportelli qui parle d'un effet
de com de Gérald hermanin et est-ce
qu'avec cette mesure qui vrait non mais
de la volonté de vouloir donner plus de
pouvoir à la police municipale est-ce
qu'il y a un risque comme le disent
certains Mair d'américanisation je suis
pas d'accord avec ça Florence por
devrait être satisfait puceque Gérald
darmanana lui propose qu'elle attend
depuis longtemps et qu'on ait
véritablement une reconnaissance de plus
de moyens plus de pouvoir la base jeis
vous répondre à la base nous sommes
officiers de police judiciaire nous les
maires et les adjoints bon donc ça veut
dire aussi qu'on est vous l'avez rappelé
responsable de la sécurité et de la
tranquillité sur notre territoire mais
pas tout seul tuas pouvoir régaler un
l'État mais une fois qu'on a dit ça
comme la santé nos concitoyens
aujourd'hui leurs deux attentes
principales c'est plus l'emploi puisque
il y a plutôt une baisse forte et tant
mieux c'est la santé et la sécurité dans
les territoires donc on doit on doit
effectivement contribuer à cela et moi
je me vois plutôt dans l'accompagnement
des services de l'État et je le dis à
mon collègue nous avons créé une police
intercommunale ce qui per per des
petites communes qui n'ent pas de police
en mutualisant d'avoir de faibles coût
et de bénéficier d'une police une
suggestion que je fais il y a peu de
police intercommunale en France moi j'ai
commun bientôt 8 ou
très bien effectivement ça permet de
recruter ça permet d'avoir plus de
PLP c'est un poli qui supprimé qu' un
système de vas
communicant pas vrai tout pas vra du
toutut D' des de police supplémentaire
parce que justement police municipale je
n'ai eu aucun départ de policiers
nationaux parce que monté en puissance
au police municipale par contre j'ai pas
assez de policiers nationaux j'ai déjà
dit à Gérald armanin il mais on l'a vu
sur les émeutes on a coordonné notre
police interco la gendarmerie qui était
venu intervenu à titre exceptionnel dans
No ver parce que c'est pas in compétence
gendarmerie et la police nationale et
c'est comme ça qu'on a pu protéger notre
centreville et les commerces qui étit
visés avec le moins de dégâts possible
alors je dis pas que c'est magique mais
c'est une coordination et oui notre rôle
il est il est de monter en puissance
j'aiermé la police j'ai eu des moyens
j'ai un CSU l'État finance le
raccordement au commissariat pour qu'on
puisse passer en vidé protection dyamque
c'estàdire suivre ce qui se passe en
temps réel pour empêcher des infractions
ou faire de la flagrance c'est pas vrai
l'état donne des
moyens ré la décision de la région a été
attaqué par l'État oui la région n'a pas
de compét
sécurité c'est commme le contribuable
local qui qui paye des taxes pour la TER
commmunaité donc on reste quand même
dans le
même efficace je suis désolé en moi je
le vis pas comme ça j'aié la police j'ai
mis de la vidéo j'ai eu des moyens vous
aussi ne dites pas que l'étatne pas
c'est jamais
suffisant interistéri à la
prévtion territo différzand vous g
sontog pourir
log deog très
bien je ser minist la
donmenter par on fait une compétence qui
est accrue il faut qu'on ait les moyens
pour la faire et moi je suis tout à fait
d'accord comme tous les maires de France
quand on transfert une compétence faut
donner les moyens
avec on écouteraisabeth on va continuer
à parler de ces sujets puisque c'est
dans la revue de presse
[Musique]
régionale etud les Mair à la de
l'actualité régionale ce matin oui des
maires qui veulent se faire entendre on
l'a Vune le libéré et qui attendent
l'exécutif au tournant à l'heure où les
violences et incivilités augmentent
contre les élus le Congrès qui se tient
à Paris cette semaine sera l'occasion
d'expliquer pourquoi ça va mal complète
la Dépêche du Midi parce que même si
c'est déjà pas mal il n'y a pas que les
violences dont s'ouvrent les élus il y a
aussi le carcan administratif les
citoyens intolérants et les faibles
indemnités conséquence 1300 élus de
proximité ont démissionné depuis 2020 le
journal qui s'intéresse aussi à la
police municipale justement celle de
Bruguière à côté de Toulouse et voilà
qui raisonne avec notre débat dans cette
commune le maire a décidé de désarmer sa
police après des alertes du médecin qui
signalait une mauvaise attente dans le
service des tensions le fait de retirer
les armes a permis d'apaiser les choses
preuve que l'armement de la police n'est
pas sans conséquence c'est pas
inintéressant et à lire dans La Dépêche
l'actualité ce sont aussi les
agriculteurs qui en aa le bol oui ça
fait la Une de l'Alsace de l'ardenis et
de l'Union les agriculteurs de l'Est
notamment qui ont organisé des barrages
filtrants pour dénoncer les lourdeurs
administrative là encore auquel ils sont
confrontés c'est le plus beau métier
mais il est de plus en plus difficile à
exercer explique-t-il il demande une PAE
normative ça résonne avec le discours du
président de la République dans le Nord
on cherche les coupables aux inondations
à qui la faute interpelle la voie du
Nord le quotidien explore trois pistes
la fatalités météorologiques les
capacités d'absorption préventive
insuffisante et les défauts de curage
des cours d'au et bien les tors sont
partagés l'état planche a des solutions
et puis le dérèglement climatique ce
sont les inondations mais aussi la
sécheresse et la montagne s'intéresse à
nos forêts les armes ne crient pas leur
douleur mais ils périssent sans bruit
dans la Creuse et ce n'est qu'un exemple
les populations d'arbres dépérissent
notamment chez les feuillus le stress
hydrique c'est la cause et le phénomène
s'accélère alors le gouvernement a bien
prévu un plan de rebroisement massif un
milliard d'arbres mais est-ce la bonne
solution et surtout sauront-ils s'adapt
et quel impact sur la biodiversité mais
bon j'allais pas vous laisser partir
comme ça sur des mauvaises nouvelles je
termine par une note positive avec une
fédération incroyable mise en valeur par
Ouest France la Fédération des trucs qui
marchent alors on a notamment le school
bus qui assure le ramassage scolaire où
tout le monde doit pédaler c'est ce
qu'on voit en une et c'est ce que vous
pouvez voir parce que l'actualité c'est
aussi les choses qui marchent on voilà
faire des smoothies en
pédalant c'est fait partie de la
Fédération des trucs qui marchent du
coup les qui pédalent pour faire dans
son pays merci christopheouillon merci
don d'avoir été avec nous merci à tous
de nous avoir suivi merci Audrey on se
retrouve demain et puis à 22h vous avez
rendez-vous avec Thomas pour s public
très bonne
journée